oh bah Gérard ma poule qu'est-ce que tu
fais là tu es rentré comment
rue gazon croise tout pareil tu avais du
chemin depuis la bande de la solo à
Montrouge avec Véronique on sortait plus
alors si on voulait voir du monde il
fallait qu'on y reçoit
[Musique]
la division
à l'époque le truc qui te gave vraiment
c'est les tournées tu as jamais été très
à l'aise avec la province
je suis venu te chercher Michel on
s'emmerde sans toi en bas ah ouais c'est
comme dans votre film la rue n'aurez pas
l'Alsace et la Lorraine quand le
chevalier blanc vient chercher le roi
groupie premier on m'appelle chevalier
blanc
à vous expliquer comment ça se trouve
un imbécile
Majesté qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
tout est prêt Majesté demain soir un
bateau vous attendra au bout du compte
va chercher Véro on leur fait la grosse
surprise ça va décoiffer ah c'est sur
cette coupe du siècle mais je peux
prendre mon Gégé il y a que trois choses
qui rentrent dans les maisons sur
s'annoncées les dettes les vieillesse et
la mort et puis tu sais bien que j'ai
pas eu le temps vieillir alors ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que quand on est
mort c'est pour longtemps banane
tu me manques aussi
mais t'inquiète mon Gégé on va se
retrouver la mort et les impôts c'est
pour tout le monde enfin le plus tard
possible quand même prends soin de toi
parce qu'après c'est pour toujours
[Musique]
pour être sûr de ne rien rater le
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu